then we have our first trailer finally
for the Dark Tower movies what is the
pretty big deal because anytime anyone I
know is read The Dark Tower ever asked
me have you read The Dark Tower and I'm
like no they're like if I should read
78,000 pages but as a fun-loving
illiterate I go into the trailer with
high hub so pretty much the kids having
visions of a tower Matthew McConaughey
the gunslinger so he goes through this
portal he sees his other world Idris
elbows like who are you any proceeds to
give this kid the obi-wan Kenobi pep
talk over a thousand generations the
Jedi Knights were the guardians of peace
and justice in the Old Republic
instead of Jedi Knights though
gunslingers instead of Old Republic it's
just shitty wasteland his scales with
that gun though did you see the way he
loads that thing a couple times you like
rolls the gun past his belt just
collecting the bullet by the time you
just click a click summon him into the
chamber one time the bullets are in the
air he just goes click pretty slick
stuff if I do say so myself
the man in black in this trailers played
by Matthew McConaughey he's also known
as flag there is he the stand
the flag same character he's like
Stephen King's devil pretty much and if
this dark tower Falls then our world is
going to be destroyed so they got to
stop that from happening however also I
have not read the stand but I saw that 8
part miniseries of the stand that came
on back in the 90s he was actually four
parts one is long and flag and there was
rats when I heard Matthew McConaughey
was playing flag I was really pumped but
it really wasn't flag McConaughey shows
up he's like a favorite fan where's I
told you a hundred like flag in the
stand I remember having a lot of
personality he was a dick but he was
funny and like it was like a likeable
[ __ ] you think I know you're the
villain but [ __ ] I get why people follow
you this way these are really ominous
dude dressed all in black it really
doesn't show off that flag personality
that I personally know maybe he was
written differently in the dark coward
book maybe the flag in the miniseries
The Stand isn't how he was actually
written in any of the books I don't know
point I just know I like that version of
flag is this one it's kind of dry in
comparison granted it's just a trailer
you see it for a couple scenes a couple
shot baby she's going to totally steal
the show I don't know [ __ ] because
good sluggers like the tower protects
both our worlds kids just look around
white well it did a fine job here your
world sucks it looks like Earth from the
Book of Eli what happened here the guns
fingers like at the tower fall
evil will unleash hell on earth the kids
like that guys the devil isn't it
gunslingers like no he's worse kid
should have been like but so doesn't the
devil unleash out what he's if you like
the devil's box how could not the devil
unleash Li by implication he's the devil
no because the devil's lame okay
have you seen McConaughey's head of Ares
wait cooler however I got to address the
fact if they go back to earth let me
really what movie did that better Smurfs
or Masters of the Universe most any time
not odd are exceptions to any rule I'm
just saying most of the time we have
this interesting lush world it's great
and then they come back to earth and
they're just losers man the moment I saw
the trailers are coming back to earth I
was like I this is just less interesting
now I'd rather stay in that world with
the ruined world and the Dark Tower and
the mr. evil is trying to destroy the
tower so our world looks like their
world anybody interesting that it's just
called the Dark Tower not the gunslinger
Dark Tower part one or dark era part one
gunslinger like by application the Dark
Tower is the only Dark Tower movie we're
actually going to get because it's
called Dark Tower not the gunslinger I
think I like if they make more they're
going to go back and a new hope it like
when the blu-rays go I was like it's
just all the other ones are Dark Tower
this and that's the Dark Tower
gunslinger this trailer was intriguing
it was interesting I wish we got more
flag of which flag really shine some
house on that I do walk away like ah
well here's a bummer but it could be
saving the goods for the movie I hope
they are so stuff to like for sure
coming back to our room I don't know how
ever tell about what you guys think so
the Dark Tower trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]